hey guys a while back I did an unboxing
video where I unboxed four pairs of
handcrafted shoes from ace marks and I
promised you guys that I'd make a honest
review about it so it's time I show you
guys what I think about these shoes and
these guys as well let's get to it now
just very quick if it's your first time
here on my channel I'm Daniel and
welcome to deal and model or lifestyle
subscribe and also clean that
notification Val
so you won't miss any of the next videos
now I've been wearing these shoes
everywhere for the last few weeks and
cold weather
in hot weather
and also even flying with that
[Music]
now I'm not gonna make the view too long
for you guys because I don't want to
waste your time but I'm quickly gonna
tell you what I liked and what I
disliked first of all all four pairs
fitted me exactly I gave a smirk to the
measurements of my feet they crafted
them and they fit me 100% perfectly now
it did not hurt me at all except for the
penny loafers that cause a little bit of
friction between the shoes and the side
of my feet now we know that breaking in
new shoes can always be a little bit
harsh on your feet and causing blisters
so I expected it with the new shoes but
it did not cause any blisters at all
with the sneakers with the Chelsea boots
and with the monk straps so I was really
impressed with that now in the unboxing
video I spoke a little bit about the
quality of the shoe so I'm not gonna
talk too much about that here but I'm
extremely happy with the quality of the
shoes and because the quality is so good
I'm also happy with the price that you
pay for it because you really get what
you pay for
now these shoes are handcrafted in Italy
with real 100% leather by
fourth-generation Italian artisans so
they know what they're doing so they
offer premium Italian leather luxury
shoes around three hundred dollars which
will actually cost you around six
hundred dollars a lot of places and so
they send it to you directly with no
retailed markups which is awesome now
they only started to create a smart at
the end of 2012
but made such a huge impression
everywhere like even places like Forbes
The Business Insider and other places
and so I gave them the measurements of
my feet and within two weeks it arrived
in South Africa which is impressive
because they handcrafted the shoes they
send it to me within two weeks and
everything always takes longer in South
Africa since then I've been wearing
these shoes in all the different kind of
situations and they look classy and
again I also got a few compliments from
other people and the most compliments I
got was for the Chelsea at Boots
I mean these guys they are just
something else and people have no shoes
they can clearly see the quality of
shoes and I've said it many times but
quality is always more important than
quantity and these shoes will last me
for a long time I mean I've been wearing
them everywhere for over a month and
they still look brand-new and for
comfort I'll give them a 9 out of 10
because the shoes are really comfortable
especially the Chelsea boots if you walk
in then they kind of improve the way
that you walk you know more streamline
if you know what I mean for some of you
that's on Chelsea boots before you know
exactly what I mean now I've only tried
these four shoes the Chelsea boots
the monks traps these black sneakers and
the penny loafers but ace marks also
have wing tips capital
and whole cuts so are they worth it yes
definitely I'll either link for you in
the video description so you can go and
check them out and also do your own
research if you liked the video give it
a thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you
in the next video
Cheers
[Music]